holy moly the iPad just slaughtered the
service pro which tablet is the laptop
replacement keying of 2022 and going
into next year well I'm gonna answer
that in this video by literally
comparing everything between these two
including the displays the designs the
performance the benchmarks the usability
with the keyboards surface pens
everything in this video to see which
one is the laptop King so let's get
started now the previous Surface Pro X
was basically unusable so let's see how
this new One Compares now before we
actually get into comparing the displays
and everything else I do want to get
into the design differences now one
thing you could see is this huge camera
bump on the iPad Pro that's because it
has the regular wide camera and the
ultra wide as well as flash lighter the
microphone so a lot going on there
compared to the surface which literally
just has the camera and a microphone
hole and one thing I can instantly
notice is the thickness of the Surface
Pro 9 because it is just so much thicker
than this super Sleek iPad and part of
the reason for that is because the
surface actually comes with a built-in
kickstand right into the actual chassis
which is fully adjustable so that's
pretty nice and the iPad doesn't have
that it relies on the magic keyboard
instead and underneath the kickstand
you'll actually find this little secret
door which is used to upgrade your
storage yes you can open this up and
upgrade the SSD up to one terabytes for
an insanely good price whereas you
literally cannot do that with the iPad
Pro which is unfortunate which means
you're going to be spending more money
and this year another difference is that
the Surface Pro 9 comes with 5G support
built in and you can actually see the
little SIM card slot right here and that
actually changes the price comparison
situation because this m2i pad Pro comes
in at eleven hundred dollars while the
Surface Pro 9 comes in at 1300 however
it has 5G support included so if you
were gonna match that up and get 5G on
the iPad it would be the exact same
thirteen hundred dollars with both
sitting at 128 gigs of storage and 8
gigs of RAM so it's a perfect comparison
now one thing you might also notice is
that the iPad is a lot wider like this
because it has a different display
aspect ratio which I'll get into so you
can see that in terms of the footprint
the surface is a little bit thinner on
this side and then finally the last
difference I want to show you guys is
the SMART connector which is right here
on the iPad Pro while the surface
chooses to put it kind of on the side
here which you connect the keyboard case
to now the Banger feature of the surface
is that it comes with two Thunderbolt
ports yes two of them compared to just
one on the iPad Pro now you might think
one of those on the surface is used for
charging but no because Microsoft has
their own proprietary charging connector
now that right there is a huge downside
for the iPad Pro but there is a little
bit of a Saving Grace and that comes
with the magic keyboard and I really
love this thing because it connects
magnetically to the iPad just like that
with the SMART connector but in terms of
that USBC Port it actually comes with a
little USBC port in the hinge of the
keyboard itself that pass through
charges the iPad Pro leaving your
regular Thunderbolt Port open and free
and then of course the Surface Pro 9 has
its own solution which is just the
bottom keyboard section and that's
because it has the flap in the back of
the tablet itself so boom it
magnetically connects to the side using
its own connector and you can adjust the
angle actually even more so than you can
with the magic keyboard which is
actually quite nice especially if you're
trying to use the pen and of course you
also have the apple pencil 2 which
magnetically connects and charges right
there at the top of the iPad Pro and
speaking of the prices for these full
setups with the pens and the keyboards
Apple solution is very expensive 480
dollars retail while on the surface side
280 dollars so two hundred dollars less
expensive for the Microsoft solution
however if you choose to not go with 5G
on the iPad Pro both of these setups
will be exactly the same price
1580 dollars so this is a perfect
comparison now I've got to admit that I
like the Microsoft solution better
because the surface pen 2 actually does
magnetically connect and charge right
there but if you close the flap it it
fully protects it and keeps it enclosed
so you don't lose it while with the iPad
Pro it's there sitting freely and you
can easily lose the Magic Pencil too now
comparing the keyboards and the track
pads first of all I want to say that I
like how the magic keyboard swipes on
this trackpad it feels a lot more
responsive and fluid and on top of that
I really dislike the click of the
surface track pad because it's using a
diving board design so at the top it
doesn't click as evenly it's actually
pretty hard to click whereas at the
bottom it's super easy now the magic
keyboard actually uses a really nice
system where you can click anywhere on
the trackpad and it's giving you exactly
the same click and feedback it's not
hard at the top so I love this a lot
better definitely a better track pad on
the magic keyboard now in terms of the
actual keys and how clicky they feel it
seems like the surface keyboard is a
little it mushy like kind of you're not
getting as good of a click compared to
the iPad where you're getting a nice
click you're getting a lot of feedback a
lot of pushback and bounce it doesn't
really feel mushy and I really like that
about it but one thing that is killer on
the surface is that you get the top row
of function keys including the escape
the brightness media keys and a bunch of
extra keys which is a big deal to me I
really love that and it's so
disappointing that we don't get that on
the magic keyboard case and the main
reason for that is because the magic
keyboard uses this cool floating iPad
design where the iPad is actually higher
and it floats and you have this
adjustable angle which is really cool
but because of that they didn't add the
function keys otherwise people would
have to reach under the iPad and
probably bump into it a bunch of times
so that's why we don't have it now the
really nice thing about the magic
keyboard for the iPad Pro is that it
makes logging in using face ID a lot
more convenient because you can simply
just hit the space bar twice to get to
your home screen however the surface
also has Windows hello with its own
infrared camera system so you literally
just hit the space bar one time and it
logs you in so it's actually better than
the face ID system now in terms of the
webcam situation the nice thing about
the Microsoft Surface Pro 9 is that you
have the webcam right there in the
center landscape just like the new iPad
10 has but unfortunately the brand new
M2 iPad Pro does not have that so I'm
looking at myself on the screen and it
looks really weird like I'm looking away
I actually have to look to the edge
where the camera is on the side to make
it look kind of normal so in terms of
video I'd say that the actual quality is
better on the iPad the location of the
webcam is much better on the surface and
you guys let me know which one has the
better microphone quality down below and
now with that out of the way let's get
right into you the speaker quality
comparison
[Music]
all right wow guys I'm actually
surprised by the speaker quality of the
surface because it was better than I
expected however the iPad destroyed it
in basically every single way first of
all the bass is better it's louder it's
deeper the mids are louder they're more
clear the vocals more clear the highs
are more sharp so across the board
better than the surface and I can feel
that the sound on the iPad Pro kind of
wraps around like a wider Sound Stage
whereas with the Microsoft Surface it
kind of comes at you directly and you
don't get that same feeling so it goes
to the iPad Pro 100 and now let's move
on to comparing the displays now the
surface technically has a 13 inch
display compared to 12 point 9 on the
iPad Pro however you actually get more
surface area on the iPad because of the
aspect ratio difference whereas the
service has a more widescreen aspect
ratio and you actually get higher
resolution on the iPad Pro as well even
though it's a 12.9 instead of a 13. now
on top of that one thing I really like
about the iPad Pro's display is the
rounded Corners all the way around which
looks really nice compared to the more
traditional flat and squared Edge
corners on the surface and on top of
that the surface has uneven bezel so you
have the huge bezel on the top and
bottom and slim bezels on the side which
of course doesn't look as good and then
in terms of refresh rate both of them
can go up to 120 hertz so they're going
to be buttery smooth and both of them
are actually adaptive as well which on
the surface you can use the dynamic mode
which switches from 60 hertz up to 120
back and forth but the app iPad Pro
actually has the win here because it can
go down to 24 Hertz automatically when
you're watching videos that are filmed
at 24 FPS which can help save you
battery life and now in terms of the
actual display quality the difference is
massive the iPad Pro has a much better
display and that's because the Surface
Pro 9 only has srgb in terms of the
color profile not even P3 wide color
gamut and the color space is also SDR
which is standard dynamic range compared
to the iPad Pro which has the mini LEDs
so it supports really good HDR at up to
1600 nits of brightness so as you can
see in this video comparison the iPad
Pro looks just so much better so much
brighter the colors pop a lot more it's
better in every way and not only that
but the standard brightness is up to 600
nits when you're just using the iPad
normally compared to only 450 on the
Surface Pro 9 so it wins there as well
and now with all that display stuff out
of the way we can clearly see that so
far the iPad Pro is winning but now
let's get into the actual performance
and Benchmark comparisons and in this
testing I'm going to take the tablets
off of their keyboards and put them flat
on the table so it's going to be easier
to see all the results now the first
thing I'm going to do is test out the
storage speed of course since the iPad
doesn't have Aja we're going to use
different apps Aja and Jazz disk and
there you go we have our numbers it
looks like the surface has 1766 for read
compared to 1575 so it is faster there
but in terms of write speed it has 651
compared to
955 so the iPad actually has the faster
writing speed so it's a little bit of a
draw right here and now getting into the
actual performance the iPad Pro of
course has the M2 Chip which has a clock
speed of up to 3.49 gigahertz compared
to the new sq3 on the Microsoft Surface
that only goes up to 3.0 at least that's
the base frequency because it's not
showing the maximum now that is an Arm
based chip and this is of course running
Windows on arms so let's see the
differences we have here and now while
this is running I do want to mention
that both of them have eight gigs of RAM
and you can get 16 on both but with the
iPad Pro you are forced to go with at
least one terabyte of storage to get 16
gigs of RAM while on the surface you can
just upgrade the RAM itself regardless
of the storage so that's nice to have
the option holy moly the iPad just
slaughtered the service pro look at that
the single core performance 80 faster on
the iPad Pro and the multi-core 50
faster is this the new sq3 yes it is
Apple has such a lead I cannot believe
it you know what it might actually be
because it was unplugged so I'm gonna
plug it into Power maybe that's gonna
allow it to be faster I don't know let's
test it again and it looks like no we
just ran it again and we have basically
the same score as before plugged and
unplugged so we're just gonna go ahead
and unplug it and make it fair like that
now if you're wondering how that's
actually going to impact your everyday
use of these tablets well it's going to
impact web browsing performance so let's
run the speedometer to web browsing
Benchmark wow there is no way the
difference is this big 380 runs per
minute compared to
103 that's almost four times fast faster
for the iPad Pro in terms of overall
snappiness for using your common apps
that use single core performance and
browsing the web as well I mean this
Difference by itself for everyday use
this could be a deal breaker but now
let's actually go and test the graphics
performance of These Arm based chips I
have the 3dmark wildlife extreme
unlimited test on both of these so let's
go ahead and run them guys this is crazy
the iPad Pro is already done with the
test and this one just finally finished
loading it up and it's not even started
this is really weird and BM it is
finished and would you look at that the
M2 Chip and the iPad Pro is 2.33 times
faster in terms of the score compared to
the new sq3 and if we compare the actual
FPS
17.6 FPS compared to
41.2 that is a lot more smooth but don't
don't worry guys I'm not gonna leave you
with just benchmarks because we have
Lightroom open right here with some Raw
photos identically the same ones on each
one so let's test the actual
responsiveness let's start with a
zooming kind of scenario where we're
just gonna zoom in and out of a couple
of places you could see nice and smooth
Zoom just like that and then let's test
it on the surface and
whoa It's like glitchy dropping frames
like crazy nowhere near as smooth wow
that's really distracting okay well now
let's switch to another photo let's see
oh the iPhone oh wow that is so slow did
you see how long it took to load that up
the iPad was basically instant let's try
it again
wow yeah that took a long time so the
iPad is more responsive switching as
well and now the final photo editing
task is to export these 50 raw 42
megapixel images and I've set the
settings to the same jpeg small
Dimensions 80 image quality so let's go
ahead and
export what in the world the iPad is
halfway done and I still don't even see
the bar on the surface it hasn't even
moved and Bam there you go the iPad has
finished
and the bar has barely moved on the
surface oh my goodness guys I cannot
believe it took that look
the iPad Pro finished in 53 seconds go
ahead and guess how long it took the
Surface Pro 9 with the brand new sq3
chip six minutes in 10 seconds yes over
six times longer than the iPad Pro I
cannot believe that the benchmarks lied
it was not that big of a difference in
the benchmarks real world was much worse
over six times longer this is an
embarrassment sq3 are you kidding me
Microsoft all right I've gotta end this
comparison there that is way too
embarrassing I would not recommend this
to anybody thirteen hundred dollars for
this kind of performance I mean that's a
premium price and you're thinking you're
getting a pro fast and responsive device
but no this is incredibly slow and
glitchy do not buy this guys between
these two it's the iPad Pro all day for
many different reasons the display
quality the speaker quality the
snappiness the performance web browsing
Graphics everything only a couple of
things were just a little bit better on
the surface I mean this is no compete
the iPad Pro wins there you guys go
that's what I think about this
comparison so if you disagree let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoy this video click the
circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign